in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
I'm in the operating theater of the DIA
car clinic vest and here in Berlin and
I'm the guest of doctor tou1 and we just
saw patient - who was getting a joint
replacement and he was not happy about
this because it didn't fill his
expectation how often does this happen
well actually it's very rare you know
join your placement is one of the most
successful surgery over the world no
other surgery has the same success rate
like joint replacement so this is very
than less ten percent less than ten
percent occasional complaint and and if
I would be a patient I would go for
joint replacement what should I look for
yeah first of all you should look that
you go to the right place for the
surgery like some we have a
certification so every year we have an
audit we have to run through and ordered
every three person coming in and see if
we do it ever seem correct so we have to
pull out our all our data all our
surgery we do and the most important
thing is actually as well that you pick
up the right surgeon that you go to the
right place is very important but then
that you have the indication as the
reason why you need the surgery so in
advanced you know if you would come in
my outpatient clinic we would make up
the proper diagnosis and then we have to
talk about your expectation it's very
important what are your expectation we
course this is an artificial joint it's
not gyro enjoyed and even your own joint
gets problems you know you got a nurse
closest because he have any deficits
whatever as I already said deformity
cartilage defect and sports injury
whatever
what's the reason that
so if we take a look at those models
here you can you can see this is Annie
and there's a Georgie placement in place
so but but but you didn't replace all
the joints it's just parts of it yeah so
just pull this tight pull like this oops
well oh dear what did i do I mess it up
and if you compare to this this is much
smaller I just thought maybe surprised
right
what would you prefer getting these huge
island yeah what do you want to trying
to do it with a smaller I would have so
much ego for this sir absolute is the
thing I would like excellent now you
need the right doctor and it's able to
say okay is this improved is that for
you or you need this implant right and
if you pull on those pull on those oh
yeah gosh yeah the big things
yeah right yeah yeah look like this how
big it is in now compared to these we
just right here I place the surface like
this much smaller we replace the tibia
much smaller right and put in and it's
mobile
I'll tell you how these 3d printers
assist you in the next years what we can
do is actually by computer technology
which gives us the possibility for
example in this case you have a damage
here in the joint line and the patella
is running through this area and this is
a people and this is a joint line this
in this party of cartilage defect
so a lot of patients just have single
defects so computer technology would
give us opportunity for example
seascape or whatever we could be able to
Obama it exactly the size the shape of
the defect and replaces with computer
technology and 3d printing we would be
able to get an individual size for the
knee is the exact radius exact radius
and they've been the proper replacement
so which is individual for this single
knee we just saw this operation ongoing
and I just wonder I think it really
looks looks very very stressful just a
patient to create it in a nice way so I
is it very hard for them to learn
walking again after this kind of surgery
no not at all even if it's working very
hard for you because you got used to see
the solitaire but the patient's running
pain for a very limited time force on
the next day or the day after surgery so
the most important thing is that it's
like a complete composition you know we
do the surgery we train the patient's
that he's able to over crutches so we
look over the patient individually and
right now you're not using 3d printers
are using those kinds of tools which
look really heavy to me like this here
this is a joint replacement and the
colors is justice I stake out the sides
absolutely this is the tibia which you
play in between the femur and the tibia
so the color is showing me the different
sizes right and then you have it at
height and this great yeah so if the
patient is getting up after surgery and
starting walking around and sometimes
you will discharge the patient from the
hospital is there anything the patient
can do to prolong the years he could use
the implant yes of course for example
you're healthy a fee-only you have a
ligament problem you just go for surgery
is a repair but if you have already a
hotter future joint for example like
this will be just replacing the surface
and you're losing for example this
ligament on the inner side of your knee
it's unstable so we are leaving
so we have to do a second operation to
give you stable to rejoin but set all
those high risk sporting events and
spotting things aside and you could use
the artificial knee as your own in other
words yeah it's a lot of lies depends on
parachuting do it but I actually don't
recommend it thank you dr. yuan for
inviting me to explain